NIRAV MEHTA: Thank
you for joining me.
My name is Nirav Mehta.
I am Director of Product
Management for Google Cloud
Compute Engine.
I'd like only 20 minutes
of your time today.
The first half, I
want to share with you
some of our recent innovations,
but also the core principles
that drive them.
And for the second half I'll
be talking with Omer Hasan, who
will join me from AppLovin.
He's the VP of Operations.
I'm very excited to have him
here for a short conversation.
So let's get right
to it and start
with some of the investment
themes and principles that
drive us.
First, Google Cloud
Compute Engine
is all about offering you
thoughtful and intuitive
choices.
What this means is
it's easy for you
to select the right virtual
machine type, the right storage
type simply by looking at how
we've organized our choices
by workloads or by use case.
And I'll talk about that
in a couple of minutes.
Second, package
solutions that allow
you to very easily, in an
opinionated way, deploy,
for example, SAP HANA, or
VMware, Microsoft SQL Server.
We've thought through
reference architectures
and common deployment
templates to help
you get to outcomes quickly.
Third, and perhaps
the most central tenet
that we have behind the
platform engineering,
is simplicity at scale.
Many customers I
talk with tell me
that Google Cloud is intuitive.
And as they use it more,
they find it simpler,
and that we make complex
things seem simple.
This is very important to us.
We take it to heart and want
to ensure we maintain this
as we grow, add more features.
So it's a commitment to
maintain this advantage,
and I'll talk
about how we do it.
Security is paramount.
Not only making sure that we
offer all the right security
controls and
compliance controls,
but also that we put privacy
in the hands of the customer,
or in the control of
you who owns the data.
A simple example of this
is our recent feature
for encrypting
in-memory contents
within a virtual machine.
The encryption keys are
controlled by the customer,
and turning the
feature on is a matter
of simply checking one box.
So simple security that's
comprehensive with the customer
remaining in control.
And lastly, cost optimization
in all its forms,
not just offering the right
price points, the right price
performance points, but also
helping you reduce waste,
making machine learning based
recommendations that tell you
what types you should
be using, how you
should be adjusting your spend.
All of that comes together
to make this a highly cost
optimized platform.
So let's talk about
each of these,
starting with VM families.
With VM families, at
the very highest level,
there are two categories--
workload-optimized
and general purpose.
For workload-optimized there
are three categories-- compute
optimized for high
performance computing,
and these are heavier on compute
power, or memory optimized,
or the M series of VMs.
This is for the high-end
databases like SAP HANA,
with very high
configuration of RAM.
And lastly, there is
accelerator optimized,
which is GPU-enabled
VMs for machine
learning training inference.
I'll talk about a
couple of these soon.
And looking at
general purpose, we
have, again, three
different categories,
ranging from price-optimized
or cost-optimized,
to price performance-optimized
for scale out.
Our cost optimized family
is called the E-series,
or the Efficient series.
If price per VM
or price per core
is the most important
consideration, that's the one
you would pick.
If you want a
balance and a feature
set that works for the long
tail of general purpose
applications, you would
go for the M series.
And the newest addition
to the VM family
is the T-Series, or the Tau VMs.
These are optimized
with a lean feature set,
eliminating waste, and offering
only the right features
for scale out digital native
applications at a very
attractive price point.
Specifically, we tested our Tau
VMs against competitive options
from leading clouds.
And as you see here, we've
achieved a price point
that's 42% better
in price performance
than anything else
from a leading cloud.
This includes anything with an
Intel, AMD, or ARM processor.
We are committed to
all these CPU types.
But what's interesting
is with Tau VMs
we've achieved the leading price
performance point with AMD VMs.
That means your
developers don't have
to go port from
an x86 application
to ARM or another
type, and still
achieve this price performance.
Tau VMs are in preview and we
are open for registration now.
An example of recent innovation
for accelerator-optimized VMs
is our A2 VMs.
These are the first VMs to
introduce the NVIDIA A100 GPU.
And I'm very proud that we
have delivered the largest
single instance VM with up to 16
NVIDIA A100 GPUs among leading
clouds, so that you can bring
your machine learning training
workloads, achieve the scale
and performance you need,
and grow with Google Cloud.
Another thing that's new
with virtual machines
is our spot VMs.
Spot VMs are a new
and enhanced version
of our pre-emptible
VMs, which allow
you to use our
infrastructure when it is not
being used by us so that you
can get very attractive price
points.
What's interesting here is we
guarantee 60% minimum savings,
which we believe is one of
the most compelling price
points in the market.
Second, and more importantly,
this pricing is predictable.
Quite often for this type of
VM you will see in the market
the prices vary
every five minutes.
In our case, these
virtual machines
are much more
predictable in pricing.
The variation is not more
frequent than once a month.
Third, Kubernetes Engine
also supports smart VMs,
so you can take advantage
of the price point
from the Kubernetes clusters.
And in doing so,
we have made sure
that the preemption, when it
does happen, is very graceful.
And lastly, you can
combine this price benefit
with custom machine types.
Custom machine types allow
you to pick the exact point
for the number of
cores and memory,
so that you don't have any waste
that is often caused by having
predefined machine sizes.
Moving on to block storage,
again, a simple set of choices.
At the very left, you
are optimized for cost.
We call it the persistent
disk efficient category.
The efficient category
will be released next year.
In the middle, as
you try to seek
a balance of price
and performance,
we have PD balanced.
And then, as you
go to the right,
you have the more
performance-intensive storage
options, PD performance
and PD extreme.
For example, PD extreme would
be used for the highest end SAP
HANA databases, delivering
up to 1,200k IOPS.
So we talked about
compute and storage.
Let me address
simplicity at scale
with two features that
were released recently.
And we are continuously
enhancing those features
with new capabilities.
First is VM Manager.
This is a suite of tools that
allow you to do three things--
patch management,
config management,
and inventory management
for operating systems.
Combined together, this
allows very easy visibility
into the posture of your
operating system compliance.
Quickly identify where
you are out of compliance,
and then launch
from the dashboard,
or in an automatable
manner, the remediation
to bring it back to compliance.
This is very important for
managing VM fleets at scale.
Having this sort
of burden and toil
removed by having it
managed by the platform
saves a lot of time
and costly labor.
Similar to VM Management,
we have this feature
called managed instance groups.
But in this case, instead
of managing the VMs,
you're actually
managing a group of VMs
as a composite application,
which is much more intuitive.
If this is what
you want to do, you
can achieve that
with Google Cloud.
For example, as shown here,
we can auto heal applications.
So for example, some of the
VMs in a group stop working.
The rest of the VMs
will take over the load.
And when the VMs are healed,
they're put back into the group
and they start managing the
load with the rest of the group.
We can also achieve autoscaling
and talk about that,
and things like auto updating.
It's very important that the
managed instance groups are
stateful, so you can deliver a
stateful application, not just
stateless applications.
We support that.
So let's talk about autoscaling.
With managed instance
groups you can scale up
and scale down as needed.
Most often customers
in the past have been
using scheduled autoscaling.
So if you're expecting
a peak at 9:00 AM, then
a little bit in advance of
that, schedule autoscaling.
And then later in the day
have an autoscale down.
With Google Cloud you can
do another thing in addition
to schedule auto scale.
You can use machine learning
to have the platform recommend
or automatically scale up and
scale down the managed instance
groups based on past
patterns of traffic.
This is very useful when
you're in a business where
you don't quite know how your
traffic might evolve over time.
And so using machine
learning at scale,
we are able to drive autoscaling
with managed instance groups.
So in summary, I've covered a
few of these core principles
that drive us.
Hopefully you see how our
investments are really
driven by all the principles
that I've shared here.
Over time I hope to come back
to you and share much more.
And now I am very excited
to have with me Omer Hasan,
VP of Operations at AppLovin.
AppLovin is a leading
marketing platform
that helps mobile app developers
grow their applications.
Omer, welcome, and thank
you for being with us.
OMER HASAN: Glad
to be here, Nirav.
NIRAV MEHTA: So Omer, let's
start with your migration
to Google Cloud.
You achieved one of
the faster migrations,
closing down several
data centers,
and coming over to Google
Cloud in a very short time.
I'd like to have you tell
us a little bit about how
you went about it.
What were some of the
key tools, practices
that you used in achieving
the speed of migration
that you did?
OMER HASAN: Yeah, sure.
Our journey did start over
on on-prem data centers.
And we found, as our
business continued to grow,
they no longer
could scale with us.
And we looked at
Google Cloud for that,
and we leveraged tools like
Google Cloud Interconnect
to help with our
migration initially,
and then tools like
Terraform and Chef
to build up our infrastructure.
We found that Terraform
was really simple
with Google Cloud, and leveraged
a lot of the APIs underneath.
And we were able to build
our data centers really
fast and efficiently.
NIRAV MEHTA: What was
the rough timeframe?
And I think you did quite a few
data centers within a few days.
OMER HASAN: Yeah, sure.
We built out our infrastructure
first on Google Cloud.
And when it came
to migration day,
we were confident enough
to do five data center
migrations in a single day.
NIRAV MEHTA: Wow, very good.
I'm sure a lot of planning,
but also a lot of skills,
thoughtful training
that went into it.
How did you go about
guiding your teams
to embrace a new concept
because they were working
with on-premise data centers?
What were some of the
observations there?
OMER HASAN: Yeah, sure.
Part of that was working
with Google's PSO team,
along with just reading
a lot of documentation
and understanding the
best practices of it.
From there, we started
to automate and build out
our Terraform
scripts and modules.
And it was easy from there.
NIRAV MEHTA: So the
support for Terraform,
having the right libraries
was important to you.
You found the Google support
to be complete enough that you
could just be productive?
OMER HASAN: Absolutely.
The Google team was
very responsive.
And if we needed a new feature,
it was built out within a week.
NIRAV MEHTA: Good.
Good to know.
With respect to once you
arrived on Google Cloud
and how you scaled up,
what benefits you saw,
can you start with
maybe, what were
some of the first observations
you had in, hey, this
is working a lot
better than it used to?
OMER HASAN: Yeah, the
impact was immediate.
We saw that in our
KPIs internally.
We saw latency drop by 25%.
We were just able to
handle a lot more.
We saw, in addition to
that, a material impact
to the business.
NIRAV MEHTA: What about SLAs?
How have your SLAs to
the business changed
as a result of this move?
OMER HASAN: We were able
to tighten up our SLAs.
Given that things were
performing faster,
we were scaled out
more, and doing this
all in the midst of
a growing business.
And I'm pretty proud to say
that we were able to just
do more, and cheaper.
NIRAV MEHTA: That's great.
Yeah, that's what
we like to hear.
Let's talk about the
network resilience,
the overall resilience
of the platform.
Where did you see advantages
in terms of eliminating
single points of failure?
OMER HASAN: Yeah, sure.
When we were on-prem we would
have NAT-based load balancers.
And we found with moving into
Google Cloud we didn't quite
need that anymore.
And by eliminating that single
point of failure, and really
a choke point, we
felt more confident
in our infrastructure.
And particularly in
failover scenarios
where traffic increased by
a lot, or significantly,
we had an ease of mind there.
NIRAV MEHTA: Great.
Yeah, good to know.
I think the collection of
different availability features
come together to support
your applications.
And knowing how you've used
those features to deliver scale
to your business is
very useful to us.
It realizes the promise of
what we like to deliver.
I want to also talk
about things that you're
doing that are above the
raw virtual machine layer.
Tell us about any
services you're using,
higher-order services in Google
Cloud beyond virtual machines.
OMER HASAN: Yeah, sure.
We're using Dataproc today.
NIRAV MEHTA: What are
you using that for?
OMER HASAN: We're using
that for our machine
learning algorithms, and being
able to do that at scale.
In fact, it was actually
one of the first services
we used at Google.
And as we were growing
and scaling our business
and doing more ML, we found
that doing that on-prem
would just be a CapEx feat.
And it would really take
a long time to build.
And so when we saw Dataproc
it felt like a natural fit.
And able to scale
out, and not only
scale out, but also
lower our SLAs,
and do that in a
cost-efficient manner.
NIRAV MEHTA: Yeah, and a
lot more elastic, I imagine.
Because the nature of
these workloads is they
go up and down unpredictably.
OMER HASAN: Correct.
NIRAV MEHTA: So that's
what you meant by CapEx,
and not having to
spend on those peaks--
OMER HASAN: Exactly.
NIRAV MEHTA: Makes
a lot of sense.
So as I reflect
back, you migrated
almost the entire platform
over to Google Cloud,
achieved a larger regional
footprint, better SLAs,
better performance,
cost savings.
We couldn't ask for more.
Thank you so much, Omer.
That is an impressive journey.
The speed with which you
migrated over to Google Cloud,
how you scaled, how you took
advantage of all our principles
to improve your resilience,
offer better SLAs,
better performance,
these are all the things
we love to see in our customer.
So thank you for taking
the time to join me
and sharing your experiences
with the audience.
To all of you out there, it's
a real pleasure to be with you.
Thank you for the time you took.
Hopefully you get a
good glimpse of what
drives our roadmaps, what
we've delivered recently.
I hope to come back and share
much more with you over time,
and also bring more
conversations with customers.
Thank you.